-President-Elect Joe Biden is
continuing with the transition
and announcing cabinet picks.
Meanwhile, outgoing president
squatters rights
fired one of his lawyers
after she claimed the election
was rigged as part of
a vast conspiracy involving
the CIA,
the Republican governor of
Georgia,
and the former president
of Venezuela
who died seven years ago.
For more on this, it's time for
"A Closer Look."
♪♪
You know, I hate to
jump the gun here
and prematurely call
the election,
but it's starting to look like
Donald Trump lost by a lot.
Joe Biden's popular vote lead is
now over 6 million.
And in total, he has more votes
than any president-elect
in history.
Or to put it another,
I don't know, more fun way,
more people came out to vote
against Donald Trump
than have ever come out to vote
against
any presidential candidate
in history of the United States.
And Donald, if you ever get mad
when you see President Biden,
know that it likely only
happened because of you.
Joe Biden ran for President
a bunch of times before this
and, like, never finished
in the top tier.
But against you, it turns out
he was the perfect choice.
Biden was like that weird kid in
school that nobody hung out with
because he smelled like garlic,
and then a vampire
attacked prom,
and everyone said,
"Quick! Get Stinky Kevin!"
And he'll never say it, but you
know when Biden told Obama
he was gonna run for president
again,
Obama must have thought,
"I'm sorry.
You didn't think being
my vice president
was the best job you were ever
going to have?
You thought it was a stepping
stone to bigger things?"
It's like a Walmart greeter
getting hired and saying,
"One day, I'm going to run
this place!"
But thanks to Donald Trump,
it happened
because more people came out to
vote against Donald Trump
than have ever come out
to vote against
any presidential candidate
in the history
of the United States.
And sure, we all know that in
the back of our minds,
that millions of people did vote
for Donald Trump,
and that speaks to a great
darkness we cannot fully handle,
but that thought
isn't going to get you
up and on the Peloton
in the morning.
So let's just bookmark it.
On top of Biden's historic vote
totals,
Georgia just certified
its results
after a vigorous hand recount,
and the Trump campaign lost
a major court case
in Pennsylvania where the judge,
a Republican member
of the Federalist Society,
did not hold back
in his contempt
for the Trump legal team's
incompetence.
-A federal judge in Pennsylvania
completely tearing apart
the Trump legal strategy
that was spearheaded
by Rudy Giuliani.
The judge in this case,
Matthew Brann,
tearing apart the claims
by the Trump team
that they wanted to invalidate
the vote in Pennsylvania
and throw out nearly
7 million votes.
The judge in this case
saying this...
-That's about as harsh as it
gets for a federal judge.
That's like hearing
Paul Hollywood say "underbaked."
Just devastating.
Netflix should really put up a
warning at the top of that show.
I also like the part where
the judge says you'd expect
the Trump legal team
to come armed with
compelling legal arguments
and factual proof.
Judge, take a hint.
When they don't come in
with briefcases,
lawyers normally have things
with them,
papers and such called evidence.
They have younger lawyers behind
them with file boxes.
Rudy and his greasers walk in
with iPhones and CLIF Bars
and a Thermos they all share.
They think this is a high school
forensics team competition
where the kid with the weirdest
adult energy wins
by talking longest.
Why would you expect this crew
to roll in with proof?
It's like expecting my burnout
cousin to come to Thanksgiving
on time with sweet potatoes.
You know he's going to show up
at 10:00 p.m. with meth
and a woman he met as a casino.
Hey. This is Sapphire,
and she's gonna be
a stripper magician.
Show 'em your stuff, babe!
By the way, I don't want to know
how Rudy and his gang
keep getting court dates to even
bring this to a judge.
They have had multiple days
in court,
and the election was, what,
three wakes ago?
Do you know how long it takes
for regular people to get
a court date?
In 2017, I was driving a zip car
in Manhattan.
My dog Frisbee jumped in
the front seat
and started scanning radio
stations.
And I was startled,
and I swerved into
a halal cart near the curb.
It was the most yelling
ever heard in New York City.
The halal vendor sued me.
Zip Car countersued both me
and the halal guy.
Meanwhile, Frisbee is suing
Sirius satellite radio
for changing "'40s on 4"
to channel 73,
the confusion that started this
whole debacle.
This happened three years ago,
and we had a hearing scheduled
for 2025 and that was only
because I pulled some strings.
Anyway, I think I was talking
about something.
Oh, right. And now prominent
Republicans such as
the governors of Arkansas
and Ohio,
Michigan Congressman Fred Upton
and Pennsylvania Senator
Pat Toomey are calling Joe Biden
the president-elect and saying
the transition should begin.
Even longtime Trump friend and
ally Chris Christie
had this to say about the Trump
legal team's efforts
to overturn the election.
-I've been a supporter
of the president's.
I voted for him twice.
But elections have consequences,
and we cannot continue to act
as if something happened here
that didn't happen.
Quite frankly, the conduct
of the president's legal team
has been a national
embarrassment.
They allege fraud
outside the courtroom,
but when they go inside
the courtroom,
they don't plead fraud
and they don't argue fraud.
If you're unwilling to come
forward
and present the evidence,
it must mean the evidence
doesn't exist.
-You know it's bad when
Chris Christie,
whose main job for years was
standing behind Trump
at press conferences like
Bobby Baccalà
waiting for his next
humiliating errand
calls you a national
embarrassment.
But Christie's other point is
important, too --
Trump's lawyers only claim
there's fraud
when they're outside
the courtroom,
never when they're inside
the courtroom.
Because court is different
from TV.
In court, you can get in real
trouble for lying,
but when they're in front of
TV cameras,
you hear all these Trump lawyers
say crazy, ambiguous,
debunked stuff about dead voters
and election software
and affidavits or whatever.
In fact, in that very hearing,
Rudy Giuliani ultimately lost.
He seemed confused about
basic legal terms
like strict scrutiny
and admitted in court
that the campaign was not
actually alleging
that fraud had taken place,
which it should be noted
is like saying in a murder
trial, "Hi,
I'm the alleged victim,
and I'm still alive.
-Actually it is a fraud case
in the sense that it's
a case brought by frauds.
Like when someone brings
a guitar case,
they are also probably a fraud.
It this wasn't a fraud case,
then what was it?
You guys keep saying there's
voter fraud in public,
but then not arguing there's
voter fraud in court.
It's like how you say in front
of your kids,
"Better be good this year
or Santa might not come."
And then at 3:00 a.m., you're on
the floor in the living room
drinking Scotch trying to tie
a bow around a light saber
screaming,
"[Bleep] paper keeps ripping!
Aah! Hey, why don't we just
have it, like,
peeking out from behind
the couch?
Just like a little piece
of light sab-- All right!
I'll wrap it.
Well, I just think it was -- the
thing is they get it as a gift.
Okay!"
In fact, they haven't alleged
any actual voter fraud at all
because it doesn't exist.
Instead they've resorted to
bat-[bleep] crazy conspiracy
theories about election software
and international communists.
And you know, one thing
I'm definitely not going to miss
about the Trump era is the
Mad Libs style news reporting.
Every time you hear about
something the Trump team said,
it's like an old Dennis Miller
joke from the '80s.
[ As Miller ] Brian Kemp
and Hugo Chávez are teaming up
to steal this election like
Kitty and Peter Carruthers
going for the gold at Sarajevo.
Okay, babe?
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] Another thing
I won't miss it trying to follow
the rotating cast of fringe
right-wing weirdos
that come in and out
of the Trump world.
Like you remember this guy,
Joseph diGenova,
the Trump lawyer and right-wing
lunatic who looks like
he got busted for trying
to sneak his own pasta sauce
on to a Pan-Am flight?
"What you guys got is no better
than ketchup!"
He basically got banned --
He got banned from Fox News
for anti-Semitism. That's like
getting kicked off Bravo
for drinking wine in a hot tub.
DiGenova was briefly
one of Trump's lawyers
during the Mueller investigation
and then got dumped
like a week later.
Even though the only question
he's ever answered is,
"What if Dennis Franz
wasn't so sexy?"
He was standing alongside
Rudy Giuliani at that insane
press conference they held last
week where Rudy re-enacted
a scene from "My Cousin Vinny"
and called the Philadelphia
Eagles a basketball team
and had what looked like
droplets
of cerebrospinal leaking from
his brain.
I guess Rudy dyed
his hair frantically
in a gas station bathroom like
Richard Kimball
in "The Fugitive."
I mean, if I saw that
coming out of my radiator,
I would be pounding
on my super's door.
Anyway, these are the only
people Trump has left
because no legitimate lawyer
wants to be a part of this
unhinged assault
on American democracy.
In fact, last week the Trump
legal team tried to delay
that hearing in federal court
to overturn the election
because in Pennsylvania,
as Reuters reported,
most of his lawyers quit.
At this point, the Trump legal
team is like CVS at midnight.
Sure, they're open, but nobody
actually works there.
And Trump is like the guy trying
to pay for AriZona iced tea
at the photo station register
who'll wait for eternity
and doesn't seem to mind.
But by far the craziest addition
to the Trump cinematic universe
has been a lawyer named
Sidney Powell.
And if you thought Rudy
was bonkers,
this lady is crazier than
a cereal mascot.
She was also at the Trump
campaign's press conference
last week and has been all over
right-ring media claiming
not just that the election
was rigged,
but that millions of ballots
were somehow faked or stolen
or whatever as part of
an elaborate conspiracy
involving the Republican
governor of Georgia, the CIA,
and the late Venezuelan leader
Hugo Chávez who died in 2013.
Until now, Powell might have
been best known playing
the uptight teacher in
every heavy metal video
or for going on Lou Dobbs' show
and making claims
about desperate migrants fleeing
poverty and violence
that were too insane
even for Lou Dobbs.
-We simply cannot tolerate the
continued invasion
of this country when Americans
are suffering every day,
the national debt is exploding.
We have diseases spreading
across the country
that are causing polio-like
paralysis of our children.
It's one thing after the other.
-You can't very well blame
that disease
on illegal immigrants.
We don't know the cause of it.
I don't know that that's --
I don't think that's fair.
A lot of, you know --
There are plenty of reasons
to keep this country secure,
including making sure
that everyone is healthy
when they are brought in to
the country without question.
Right? Is that fair?
-That is fair, but that is part
of the problem.
We don't know where the diseases
are coming from.
-Well, that's -- you know what?
I think that -- With that,
we're going to leave it.
-It's always fascinating to
watch these people have a brief
moment of self-awareness.
You'd think after that interview
Lou Dobbs would have maybe,
I don't know,
pulled it back a little?
It's like when you're at a party
and everyone's feeling good
and then it gets late
and someone says,
"Let's get on the roof and jump
in the pool."
And everybody else says, "Yeah!"
But then you remember
the apartment is 12 stories high
and there's not a pool.
So you quietly sneak out
the back.
But then the next night,
they're like,
"We're having another party."
And you're like, "All right."
Anyway, that's the psycho
who showed up
to the official Trump legal
team's press conference
on Thursday and claimed not just
the mail-in ballots
were fraudulent
or that dead people had voted,
but that there was a vast
international communist
conspiracy involving
a dead Venezuela leader
to subvert the election.
-What we are really dealing with
here and uncovering
more by the day
is the massive influence
of communist money through
Venezuela,
Cuba, and likely China
and the interference
with our elections here
in the United States.
The Dominion voting systems,
the Smartmatic technology
software and the software
that goes in other computerized
voting systems here as well,
not just Dominion,
were created in Venezuela
at the direction of Hugo Chávez.
-You know, she doesn't make
a lot of sense,
but at least has the same voice
as an orphanage headmistress
whose catch phrase is, "You
ain't never getting adopted."
Still nice to know that dead
people who are voting
are Hugo Chávez.
Who else voted in this election,
Boutros Boutros-Ghali?
[ Laughter ]
-So Powell alleged a vast
conspiracy involving Hugo Chávez
to help Joe Biden win
the presidential election,
and yet curiously, she kept
refused to provide evidence
of this vast scheme when
pressed,
even by friendly Fox News hosts
who are basically desperate
to agree with her as long as she
can provide a shred of evidence.
-So, Sidney, you feel that you
will be able to prove this?
Do you have the software in your
possession?
Do you have the hardware
in your possession?
How will you prove this, Sidney?
-Well, I've got lots of ways
to prove it, Maria,
but I'm not going to tell on
national TV what all we have.
-So we invited Sidney Powell
on this show.
We would have given her
the whole hour.
the entire week, actually,
and listened quietly the whole
time at rapt attention.
That's a big story.
But she never sent us
any evidence,
despite a lot of requests --
polite requests.
Not a page.
When we kept pressing,
she got angry and told us
to stop contacting her.
-Wow, you know you're in full
loony territory when even
Tucker Carlson won't go along
with what you're selling.
He was begging her to come on
his show?
Good Lord, it's easy to get on
television these days.
Unhinged people used to have to
stand behind a reporter
on location and jump up and down
yelling, "Baba booey!"
Anyway, the point is
Sidney Powell was somehow
even too insane for the Trump
legal team,
which by the way, repeatedly
told everyone
they considered her a member
of that legal team.
They tweeted many times that she
was working with Rudy
in an official capacity
for the Trump campaign.
The official GOP account tweeted
out a clip of her remarks
and she appeared at the official
campaign press conference
on Thursday.
But I guess she went too far
even for Trump over the weekend
when she went on the far-right
Newsmax channel and claimed that
the Republican governor
of Georgia, staunch Trump ally,
was somehow part of the plot
along with Hugo Chávez
and also the CIA.
-Georgia's probably going to
be the first state
I'm going to blow up,
and Mr. Kemp
and the Secretary of State
need to go with it,
because they're in on
the Dominion scam
with their last-minute purchase
or award of a contract
to Dominion of $100 million.
The State Bureau of
Investigation for Georgia
ought to be looking into
financial benefits received
by Mr. Kemp
and the Secretary of State's
family about that time.
And another benefit Dominion
was created to award
is what I would call
election insurance.
That's why Hugo Chávez had it
created in the first place.
But I also wonder where he got
the technology,
where it actually came from.
Because I think it's Hammer
and Scorecard from the CIA.
-Can you tell us anything?
Can you make some news with us
here tonight?
Tell us anything new
that you're going to present
in that filing in Georgia.
-Well, I can't say that yet.
But hopefully this week,
we will get it ready to file.
-Sidney --
-It will be biblical.
-Okay. Wow. So the governor
of Georgia is being bribed
by an election software company
created by Hugo Chávez
as part of a vast plot involving
the CIA
to spread communism
across the globe.
Because first of all, the CIA
loves helping out communists.
We all remember when the CIA
helped install Fidel Castro
in the famously successful
Bay of Pigs Invasion.
Second of all --
Wait, why am I saying second?
Why am I breaking this down
point-by-point
like anyone watching this
is still on the fence thinking,
"Okay. All right.
But what about your next point?"
Apparently I'm not the only one
who feels this way
because the Trump campaign
issued a statement yesterday
suddenly distancing itself
from Powell.
-Just over a week after
President Trump named
attorney Sidney Powell to his
legal team in his effort
to overturn results
of the 2020 election,
the president's legal team now
says that Sidney Powell
is not a member
of his legal team.
Rudy Giuliani and Jenna Ellis,
two of the attorneys
for the president's effort
saying in a statement...
-It's both insane that they're
trying to pretend
she was never part of the legal
team when she was literally
standing at an official Trump
press conference
and also believable that someone
could wander into
a Trump press conference and say
they're his lawyer.
She was identified on TV
as his lawyer.
There's no getting out of that
one. But what about DiGenova?
I'd buy he heard there was
a thing
where you don't need a mask
and showed up.
Hey, uh, brought my own sauce.
Okay?
Just if you need it.
By the way, as a side note,
you don't need to announce
who's joining and leaving
a legal team.
A lot of times people show up to
court and the lawyers are there
and then you know.
Not everyone tweets...
Personally, I'm just
disappointed because Powell
kept promising blockbuster
evidence of fraud
and now I guess
we'll never see it.
She even used an especially
memorable phrase.
-This looks like the effort
to --
to carry out an end game
in the effort against him.
Do you concur?
-Oh, absolutely. And it's been
organized and conducted
with the help of Silicon Valley
people.
The big tech companies,
the social media companies,
and even the media companies.
And I'm going to release
the Kraken.
-I guess the only Kraken we
ended up seeing
was in Rudy Giuliani's hair dye.
They have no evidence, which
is why lawyers keep quitting
or getting fired or laughed out
of court because
this whole thing isn't actually
about evidence.
It's about manufacturing
a conspiracy theory
that will animate Trump's base
for years to come.
It's just another scam like
Trump's many previous scams.
In terms of actual legal
arguments,
the Trump team's case
is deader than...
-Hugo Chávez.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over 2 million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the "donate" button.
Stay safe, wash your hands,
wear a mask. We love you.